All right. Welcome everybody
to our educational session on continuous oncology wearables,
digital biomarkers, and the future of cancer interception.
My name is Peter Kuhn. I'm a university professor at the University of Southern
California in Los Angeles.
But before we start, I wanted to particularly welcome patients and advocates who
might be with us in the audience. I'm glad that you guys are here.
And
as we go through Q&A, the way we're setting up the session is
that we will do 20 minutes per presentation with five minutes of
Q&A,
so that we end up having about 15 minutes of
combined Q&A at the end
of this.
I'm super excited for the session in particular because we have,
I think, Charissa, you're a clinical health psychologist, right?
And Georgia is an information engineer by training.
Jorge is an actual medical oncologist,
so he's the physician in the room, and I'm a physicist by training.
So hopefully we'll get a conversation actually going between all of us
and through these
different lenses, actually look at this topic.
Jorge and I actually have taken a run at this now seven years ago
at the AACR in 2019, and we did a bit of a playful
construct of physician versus physicist.
Because at the time, again, there was this idea of like, hey, the physics, we
measure stuff,
but the physician actually is there to actually advise the
patient and develop a treatment plan.
And
then this construct of actually how do we actually work together, right?
Because in the end, it's not measurement for the sake of measurement,
but it really is about understanding the disease,
and then really figuring out how can we actually improve outcomes through
interventions.
Still, I would argue still today,
very much we look at cancer and cancer care as
snapshots in time,
maybe as far going as far as episodes is concerned.
But that's really driven by how we observe it.
It is not how the patient experiences it, because the patient, of course,
experiences it
as a continuum.
So all of that framing, I think, is just there for us as
a cancer research community to really think about
what does that mean? How do we actually take that forward?
And the not allowable one is to say, "Well, that's too complicated." Because again,
what we really need to do is actually understand
the human physiology and how it impacts
the patient, and then how can we actually understand that
evolving physiology, and then how can we measure that evolving physiology, and
then how can we manipulate it for better outcomes.
So with that,
I'm actually going to make the introduction really short here to
make room for Charissa,
who is joining us from the University of Pittsburgh
and UPMC.
And this is really the most clinically grounded work, I think, in this space for us
today.
And with that, I'll just hand it over to you directly.
As we go into Q&A, please, everybody, walk up to the microphone, introduce
yourself with name and affiliation, maybe really quick.
But always use the microphone so that our online audience can hear your
question as well.
Great. Thank you, Peter.
And thanks for the opportunity to share with you all some of the work that we're
doing at the University of Pittsburgh and UPMC Hillman Cancer Center.
So what I'd like to talk to you today about is an opportunity for all of us as
cancer researchers and clinicians
to better understand if a new experimental treatment is impacting patients'
physical functioning, to identify which patients may be at risk for
readmissions or falls after a long hospitalization, and to do this
using data that many of your patients are already collecting.
So you can tell by my title, I'm talking about consumer wearable devices.
And these include things like Fitbits, Apple Watches, Oura Rings, things that
anybody can buy at Amazon or Best Buy.
Can you all hear me?
Thank you. Can I just see a show of hands for who owns one of these devices
or is wearing one right now?
Thank you.
So most of these measure objective behavior, including physical activity and
sleep. So since they're measuring actual behavior, they really capture something
different and less prone to recall and reporting biases than just
asking a patient how much they exercise or how well they sleep.
A lot of these also measure continuous physiology, things like heart rate, pulse
oxygenation, skin temperature.
Our most recent surveys from a couple of years ago suggest that nearly half of all
US adults own and use a wearable device, and that ownership does tend to be
concentrated among the younger, wealthier, more educated
segments of the population, but that use is growing in all subgroups.
And because users tend to wear these 24/7,
we really are able to get a glimpse into the 99% of patients' lives when they are
not in our clinical spaces in front of us.
So we're able to capture their behavior and physiology between clinical
visits as they're going about their usual daily
routines in their homes and their communities when they're doing the things that
matter most to them. And some reasons for why I think we should think
about incorporating them into cancer care is that they're relatively inexpensive
and easy to use.
Important for remote monitoring is that the data can be accessed remotely,
regardless of where the provider or the patient is.
And in relatively real time, so that data can be actionable, we can pick up pretty
quickly if something's going on with a patient.
And because we're collecting such rich 24-hour data on patients, we can really get
a sense of what's normal for that patient.
What does their baseline look like, so that we can potentially pick up on subtle
shifts in their health and
functioning.In
our lab, we've mostly used Fitbit Inspire devices, although I think the
findings that I'll be presenting would generalize to data collected from other
devices. And we've picked Fitbits for a few different reasons.
First, they're pretty cheap at less than $100 per device.
So this is important both for constrained grant budgets, but also for future
scalability.
Also important to us is that they're compatible with both iPhones and Android
devices, unlike something like an Apple Watch or a Samsung watch.
So this means that the patients can enroll in our studies or our monitoring
protocols regardless of what kind of smartphone they have and use their own
smartphone to sync the device and set it up.
Fitbit Inspires have a 10-day battery life, which minimizes the burden on patients
in terms of charging the device and remembering to put it back on.
And the Fitbit Open API allows us to access data,
granular intraday data that includes step count every minute, heart rate every few
seconds, and sleep and physiology overnight.
And there's evidence accumulating for sleep, for activity, and heart
rate at least that these measures are relatively accurate compared to gold standard
measures.
So our team has collected Fitbit data from over 500 patients living with cancer
over the past several years. We've developed a number of resources and procedures
to try to make this as easy as possible for patients and for investigators.
So if you're interested in doing this, please talk to me after the session.
So the first question is: Is it feasible to collect Fitbit data during active
cancer treatment? So when we're talking about active cancer treatment, we're
obviously talking about older patients for the most part, patients that may not
have a lot of digital health literacy or familiarity with wearable devices.
And if they're going through chemotherapy or cancer treatment, they might not be
feeling well. They might be feeling overwhelmed.
Is this too much to ask for them to also collect this additional data stream?
So this was a study led by a former medical student, Sean McLean.
We enrolled 162 patients getting chemotherapy for any solid tumor.
The patients in our sample were primarily gastrointestinal, pancreatic,
breast, and other solid tumors. And they were asked to wear a Fitbit device that we
provided for 90 days, and we encouraged them to keep it at the end of the study.
Patients on average were 60 years old, but we had people as old as 92 enroll in
our study, 62% female, 83% white, and you can see that over
two-thirds had stage four cancer. So at least some patients were relatively sick.
So in our lab, we use the availability of heart rate data to indicate wear
time, and we set a minimum threshold of eight hours.
We want patients wearing the device for at least a third of the day and around half
of their waking hours if we're going to include that step count in our assessment
of how active they were that day.
And we found that on average, patients met that threshold on 70% of study
days over the 90-day study, which we found encouraging.
It suggests that we're getting a pretty good sense of how active people are
being out in the real world in between their clinical visits and their
chemotherapy infusions. Also really encouraging and important to us was that we
didn't see this rate decline over time.
So we didn't see that people eventually got fed up with the Fitbit and stopped
wearing it, that they stopped charging it or remembering to put it on.
Rates were pretty consistent throughout the 90 days, suggesting that we may be able
to extend this monitoring period even further.
We also looked at sociodemographic and clinical factors related to Fitbit
adherence.
We found an effect of age, but in the opposite direction that we hypothesized.
We actually found that our older patients were better at collecting Fitbit data
than our younger patients.
No gender difference. We found a pretty striking race difference with our non-white
participants.
Again, only 17% of our sample, but they had much lower rates of Fitbit adherence,
so we're still digging into trying to understand the reasons for that and how we
can mitigate that disparity.
No difference by education or rurality.
We found that patients that came into the study with any level of cognitive
impairment by self-report also struggled a little bit with the Fitbit data
collection.
No difference by depression or cancer stage, again, by study day or
weekend or weekday.
We did find that patients were better at collecting Fitbit data in the days right
after their chemotherapy infusions, which may partly be an artifact of the fact
that we often showed up in the infusion room to help them sync their Fitbit, get
re-logged in, but also may indicate that
those days right after their infusion when they were experiencing the most side
effects, maybe their health and wellbeing was more top of mind, and they were
remembering to keep the Fitbit charged and on their body.
So this is my answer to can we do this?
Can we collect Fitbit data during active cancer treatment?
So next I'm going to turn to should we do this?
Is there any clinical value in these Fitbit data in terms of cancer outcomes?
So the first study we did in this space was looking at hospital readmissions.
So we enrolled 54 patients undergoing surgical treatment for metastatic peritoneal
cancer. So if any of you are surgeons or have had surgery or helped somebody
through surgery, you know that patients are always told to get up and get moving as
soon as possible after you've had surgery, that that will speed their recovery and
healing. But this is rarely quantified systematically.
So that's what we set out to do. We gave patients a Fitbit to wear from the time
that they left the ICU and were ambulatory until their hospital discharge, which
was around 12 days for most patients.
These patients were getting cytoreductive surgery with hypothermic intraperitoneal
chemotherapy, which is a pretty grueling procedure with a high complication and
readmission rate. And consistent with that, we found that 39% of our patients
were readmitted within 60 days.
And when we looked at how active they had been during that inpatient recovery, we
saw that the patients that left the hospital after their surgery and did not come
back were more active. They were taking around 1,250 steps per
day, which is significant right after a major abdominal surgery.
Suggests some intentional efforts to get up and walk around the hallways.
The patients that were readmitted were more around 500 steps a
day. And this effect persisted even after we adjusted for things that might be
related to both activity and readmission, so age, comorbidity,
BMI, and length of stay. So I'm not suggesting that this is causal.
There's a lot of other factors that could be at play here, but it does suggest that
these pretty easy-to-collect Fitbit data may help us figure out
who after these surgeries might benefit from additional support and
monitoring.So
step count is kind of the first thing you think about when you think of Fitbit
devices. But because we're collecting continuous data over 24 hours, there's a
lot of other information that we can extract from that data.
So a former postdoc, Dr. Julio Vega, developed an open source pipeline for data
cleaning and processing called Rapids.
If you work in this space, I encourage you to check it out at rapids.science.
So we've been using this to compute additional features.
We're always adding to the pipeline.
We
like other contributors to add things as well.
So some things that we've been adding and focused on the last couple of years that
we think are nice complements to step count, which really reflects the amount of
walking activity,
is peak gait cadence, which is maximum steps per minute, which really reflects the
intensity of walking at peak effort,
and activity fragmentation, which is the probability of transitioning from an
active to a sedentary state. So if somebody is walking, do they need to stop and
rest? And this reflects stamina while walking.
So we picked these because, in the research-grade accelerometry literature, there's
some evidence that these metrics predict frailty,
falls, and mortality in community-dwelling older adults.
They've not really been looked at in the context of cancer, and these haven't been
extracted from consumer wearable device data before.
So we were interested in whether we could do that with Fitbit data and whether
those would be predictive of any important clinical cancer outcomes.
So we first did a study with post-treatment cancer survivors, and here we were
focused on survivors aged 65 and up who may be at elevated risk for things like
falls and functional decline. We enrolled 40 survivors of any
cancer within five years of treatment.
We had them come into our lab and do some objective performance-based
physical functioning tests, including the Short Physical Performance Battery.
We also had them fill out questionnaires to assess their self-reported physical
functioning. And then we had them wear a Fitbit for a month and computed these
variables.
And in terms of correlations, we found that step count was
correlated with patient-reported physical functioning and the Short Physical
Performance Battery score.
Correlations were maybe even a little stronger for gait cadence and activity
fragmentation. When we adjusted for age and comorbidities, only
peak gait cadence was related to PROMIS physical functioning,
although all features remained associated with that objective performance-based
physical functioning.
We also found that about a third of participants reported a fall or a near fall
during the one-month study. So we were interested in whether these variables were
useful for predicting falls.
So in some regression analyses, again, adjusting for age and comorbidities, we
found that faster peak gait cadence alone was associated with significantly reduced
fall risk during that one month.
We did some ROC curve analyses that suggested that peak gait cadence was able to
differentiate those survivors at risk for falls versus those not, and that the
optimal threshold for cutoff was around 100 steps per minute, which is like a brisk
walk.
Next, we turn to see whether this could predict survival.
So this is an extension of that earlier sample of patients
getting chemotherapy for any solid tumors.
We had 213 patients enroll and wear the Fitbit for 90 days.
We followed patients for a median of two and a half years, and we found that 42% of
patients died during that time. In univariate analyses,
we found that step count did predict survival.
So did peak gait cadence and activity fragmentation.
But when we adjusted for age and cancer stage and type, only the latter two
variables, only peak gait cadence and activity fragmentation remained
significant.
So you can see our Kaplan-Meier curves here.
So on the
top panel, you can see gait cadence, the participants walking whose peak
gait cadence was 100 or more
in the yellow line on top had better survival, and in the bottom, you can see that
the patients that had more fragmented activity in the yellow had
greater mortality over the follow-up.
And so as I said, these associations persisted when we adjusted for age, cancer
stage, cancer type. Also importantly, they persisted when we adjusted
for clinician-rated ECOG performance status, when we adjusted for
patient-reported physical functioning.
And I didn't do this in the paper, but I thought of it later and also adjusted for
step count, and these associations remained when we adjusted for step count.
So suggesting that these gait cadence and activity fragmentation measures might be
capturing something independent of what clinicians can perceive, what patients can
perceive, and something different than just a generic step count.
Alongside this quantitative work, we've been doing some qualitative studies with
both clinicians and patients. Talk about the work with clinicians today.
So we interviewed 13 oncology clinicians who did some questionnaires.
We also interviewed them to try to understand their preferences around how we may
integrate some of this wearable device data into clinical care, clinical
decision-making, and into patient-provider communication.
During the interviews, we had a few clinical vignettes where we
had some clinical information, and then alongside that showed some data
from the past participants in our studies, some wearable device data, to see
whether that had any influence on their clinical decisions and recommendations and
their confidence in those decisions.
Overall, the clinicians did report that the data from wearable devices improved
their confidence and their clinical understanding and decisions.
Just have a couple illustrative quotes here.
"It'd be nice if someone's calling me with questions, I can just pull up this data
and see what's really going on between visits."
"Sometimes I feel like patients don't want to be dose reduced and they'll lie.
I try to get their family to rat them out, like, 'Are they really grocery shopping
and cutting the lawn?' And they say, 'No, they're sitting on the couch all day.'"
So what we heard a lot from clinicians was that this wearable device data was a
nice complementary piece of information that could corroborate or
help to resolve discrepancies in reports, kind of what they were seeing, what the
patient was telling them, what the family was telling them.
And so while it didn't necessarily change their recommendation or decisions, it
just gave them greater confidence in those decisions and understanding.
So some lessons learned so far.
Consumer wearable device data can be reliably collected from even older advanced
cancer patients and for several months and perhaps longer during active treatment.
Fitbit metrics, at least in our preliminary, pretty small samples,
but they suggest that these Fitbit metrics are related to readmission risk after
cancer surgery, physical functioning and fall risk after cancer treatment, and
survival after chemotherapy.And that peak gait cadence and activity
fragmentation from these devices may be more prognostic than step count in the
context of cancer and might also capture information about real-world
functioning, independent of what clinicians and patients perceive.
And oncology clinicians,
at least the ones we talked to, believe that wearable device data could improve
confidence in clinical decisions.
In some ongoing work, we're trying to figure out how can we best share these data
with oncology patients and clinicians. Do they want alerts?
Do they want visualizations of these data that they can sift through and find
patterns on their own? Do they want to receive things via email, in-app
notifications? So we have a single-arm trial ongoing right now with
39 patients. Our cancer center is currently transitioning to Epic this year,
so we had some limitations in being able to integrate anything into the medical
record, not this year.
So what we're doing in this trial is we're using patient
smartphones to have them complete a daily patient-reported outcome measure
assessing seven common symptoms during chemotherapy.
If symptoms are mild, they get some self-management advice that are based on
clinical guidelines that pop up within the app.
If they endorse anything moderate to severe, they get an alert that they should
consider contacting their clinician to discuss these symptoms, especially if they
persist or worsen.
They're also wearing a Fitbit device.
We have an automated nightly script that's running each night to check their Fitbit
data for low pulse ox, elevated skin temperature,
a heart rate that's 10% higher than that patient's historic average,
or a step count or gait cadence that's significantly lower than their historic
average. And if any of these are detected, again, they get an alert saying, "You
might want to consider discussing this with your clinician, especially if you're
also experiencing symptoms."
In addition, we have a weekly script that's automatically generating and emailing
patients a report that's visualizing this data, which we encourage them to share
with their family members, their caregivers, as well as their clinical care team.
And here's just some screenshots from those reports.
So we have a heat map showing the different symptoms that are reported daily,
decreased appetite, fatigue, the kind of common symptoms that patients
report. And then you can see some graphs of their Fitbit data, and the red dots are
any time an alert was triggered, an email sent to them, or an alert sent to the
patient suggesting they talk to their clinician.
We're also doing similar remote monitoring studies in the context of cystectomy for
bladder cancer, as well as for patients getting immune checkpoint inhibitors for
melanoma.
Clinicians are really busy. They may or may not want to sift through all these
lovely graphs that we're generating for them, so we're also exploring the role of
AI in summarizing these data for clinicians to see whether LLMs may be
useful in generating narrative summaries that may be easier for clinicians to
integrate into their workflows.
And we're developing patient-facing tools to help them identify patterns in their
wearable device data to guide behavioral change or to prepare
for their clinical visits and their conversations with their
clinicians. So I'm really excited about this field.
I'd be happy to collaborate with anybody here, and I'm excited to hear from my
fellow panelists about where we can consider taking this field more broadly.
So I'd like to acknowledge our-- We have a great interdisciplinary team at the
Mobile Sensing and Health Institute at Pitt.
You can check out our projects on our website.
The patients and clinicians who participated in this work, most of our funding has
been from NCI, and thank you all for listening.
Any questions, please come up to the microphone.
Carissa, maybe one quick question.
When you show the data on predicting falls,
have you tried to see how early you could predict
that reliably, right? It's one thing to-
Yeah
... retroactively say-
Right
... we can separate those two, but-
Yeah
... how do you think about that?
Absolutely. No, we have not
attempted that yet. I think that's really critically important.
What kind of early warning time window does that give us?
I think that is really the important question, because a lot of what I'm presenting
is retrospective analyses where we're looking at data that's been collected and
linking it to clinical outcomes. But whether when actually deployed, we're able
to predict things sooner than we otherwise would have and act
sooner is still an open question.
Hi there. I'm Chi-Chun Hong from Roswell Park Comprehensive Cancer
Center. So we're trying to get into this field as well, and we're
trying to, right now, put together a study of
1,000 metastatic breast cancer patients across five different states,
and we're trying to use some of these sensors.
And I'm just wondering if there was a process for you to get to
Fitbit as opposed to some of the other devices out
there.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yes, we tried at least a dozen wearable devices when we were starting
out. Again, I showed some of the rationale for selecting Fitbit.
We really did want something that was platform agnostic that could work
across
both Android and iPhones. A lot of our older patients do have Android phones,
and where there was an open API that we could work with.
And we landed on Fitbits back in 2016, 2017, and have just
stuck with it because that's the infrastructure that we've been developing.
And I think there's a lot of advantages and disadvantages.
I think now that they've been acquired by Google, there's some additional hiccups
that we're working through. But I do think that patients generally find them really
comfortable and easy to use. A lot of patients have Fitbits already, and if so,
we're just able to access data from their account.
Right. Okay. We ended up going with Garmin, and I'm like having to rethink
this. Can I ask one more question?
Of course.
So we ran into some issues where some of the patients came
back and they said, "I wear Apple Watch. This is what I'm going to wear.
I don't want to wear a Garmin."
Yeah.
Have you dealt with trying to
bring together these different kinds of data and letting patients wear what they
want to wear?
Yeah, I would love to get to that point.
I think it's complicated if you're trying to work directly with the data.
There are a number of companies out there that are data aggregators, where you can
contribute whatever data from whatever device and pull that in.
And then I think they have ways of harmonizing the data so you can consider step
count from whatever device the patient is already owning and using.
And that might be a way to go. They're kind of expensive, those companies, but-
Okay
... I think, yeah, in terms of pragmatically integrating these
into clinical workflow, I think letting people use what they have is going to
be really important for engagement.
Okay. Thank you.
Karissa, one more question on the-
Yeah
... on the data. So you're returning data to the patient.
What you showed was a fairly pragmatic return of data.
Mm-hmm.
Somewhere along the way, you're going to return interpreted data
or data interpretation. Where is that balance on the
IRB in terms of-
Mm-hmm
... returning results on a research approach?
How does that work?
Yeah.
What can we learn from your experience of how to actually design this?
Yeah. I'm definitely not an expert in this space, and we have really tried to toe
the line of regulatory, like not crossing the line into being a
medical device. We're not trying to diagnose anything.
And yeah, the data that we're returning, the IRB has determined is not
diagnostic or anything too interpretive.
I think,
it's really a changing landscape.
since we're not
providing data in real time, that since we're not using it to affect insulin
dose or anything like that, it's been okay for IRB.
But yeah, I'm definitely not the best person to ask about this.
I think it is a question that we all need to put our heads together to figure out
how to get data to patients that is actionable and useful for them, but
that isn't going to introduce more risks that we don't quite understand.
Yeah.
Hi. Have you attempted any temporal mapping of
activity trends with when they had
treatment and what type of treatment perhaps too?
Are there any insights from that?
Yeah. That's a great question.
Not in the most interesting way. We have looked at
day-level data after chemotherapy infusions to see, and as you might expect,
people do become less active.
I'm interested in whether circadian
rhythms change a bit. We notice that people walk a little bit slower in the days
after chemotherapy, but that's just at a population level.
It would be really interesting to dig into that
at a more patient level and to do it in a
more sophisticated way, because I think there's just such richness to
this data.
And I think,
we're still trying to figure out the best analytic approaches to handling this kind
of time series data to really pull the signal out and figure out what's most
meaningful.
Thank you.
Excellent. All right. Thank you, Karissa, one more time.
So next up is Giorgio. He's joining us from UCSD.
And I think he's actually going to broaden the lens a bit of really looking
at wearable sensors and digital medicine,
but coming at this from looking at a couple of different diseases, not cancer.
I think it's also your very first AACR conference, I assume, right?
So welcome to the club. The floor is yours.
Thank you so much, and thank you so much to everyone. So I'm Giorgio Aquile.
I come from Scripps Research,
here in San Diego. And I'm here to talk
to you about wearable device and artificial
intelligence, and in particular, their application to digital medicine.
So we'll see different
clinical scenarios in which we applied this technology,
and we'll work together to see how this can be
also useful for oncology and for the
trials that you are running. And we are welcoming, of course,
any type of collaboration. So,
to start, I don't have any relevant
relationships to disclose.
Let me start from the very beginning.
Why are we using wearable sensors?
And so what you see here is the result of a
study with about 100,000 individuals, in which you
look at a very, very simple
measure, the resting heart rate. And what you see there, how the
resting heart rate, so basically, your heart rate on a daily
basis when you're at rest,
usually monitored in the early morning before waking up from bed.
This can change a lot from different individuals.
It can go from more than 90 pulse per minute for some individual to
about 40, 45 pulse per minute for some others.
So,
it's difficult, also, just to start with, to put maybe
threshold and see when it is good and when it is not.
And,
let's go a little bit deeper into a very
practical example. This is one individual.
What you see on the left is the resting heart rate and,
full disclosure, that individual is myself.
We start with
my average resting heart rate is around 55 pulse per minute when
nothing else is happening. And as you see there, it starts at the--
well, this is mid-July. It's around 55, and then it goes
up with the days till
mid-August, more or less.
What's happening here? Well, I was traveling internationally, and so I
was traveling from here to Italy and Finland, different time zones.
Something was changing, for me,
bad sleep probably, different food, and so on.
And so you see an increase. And then I came back to San Diego.
It all went back to normal around this 55.
There is a small peak there. This was a long weekend.
This was Labor Day, I think.
Some different food and maybe drinks. Went back to normal.
And then you see on the right, it starts to increase.
It increased
significantly. It's an increase for about two
weeks.
I didn't realize anything till really after two weeks in which I was not
feeling super good. I was planning to go to the doctor,
and really the day after, I got very high fever, about
103 Fahrenheit. I went to the emergency care.
They did a bunch of exams. They figured out I have
bacterial infection. They gave me some antibioticsCame back a
couple of days after they saw the exam and said, "No, no, you need some stronger
antibiotics" and whatever. Long story short,
everything was resolved within about a month.
But I learned quite a few interesting things here.
So first of all,
this wearable
sensor was showing a difference
two weeks before I even realized there was something.
The changes are very individualized.
Even when I was at the very top here of my
problem, it was about 77 pulse per minute, which is totally normal for
most of the individuals. It was just 20 pulse per minute higher for
myself.
And then another really important thing that we need to
keep in mind every time we use these wearable devices, this is really not
specific. So, there are a lot of factors that
influence how the sensor changes, from
travel to long weekend to an illness, and
stress and much more. So we need to keep all of that into
consideration. And today,
I'll drive you through how we use it in very different
domains that we are working on at the Digital Trial
Center at Scripps Research, from infectious diseases to
maternal health, precision nutrition, heart health, sleep medicine, and more.
We start with infectious diseases.
And
first things first, so what do we mean by digital trials?
So these are trials done fully
remotely. So we never meet in person with
the participants. The participants are
anywhere in the United States. We recruit them fully
remotely. They have an informed consent that they sign remotely.
And,
for all these trials, they don't visit a hospital.
We provide them with the tools to get interesting data.
And we'll see
through the different ones what are the differences.
So let's start with
infections. So,
as I showed in the example, there is an opportunity for an early
detection of infectious diseases.
In particular, this is a study we did
at the very beginning of the COVID-19 pandemic.
We were able to launch the study at the end of March of
2020, so just a few weeks really after it
started. We recruited in about three months, more than
40,000 individuals through anywhere in the
United States, from all 50 states.
And we showed, for the first time, how a wearable
device can help in the early
detection of this type of infectious diseases.
We show how a device can basically anticipate, a
little bit, the symptoms and figure out who is
infected,
with a certain probability of course.
The AUC at the top was about 0.8,
but still providing a significant information.
And
then, in the same study, we went to a second step and say,
"Well, fine is to monitor and predict.
Now, can we really action? And what
happens if we action in this context?" And,
we run
a trial that we call Detect Ahead,
in which basically we randomize about 450 people
into people who receive this suggestion
based on our algorithms or based on symptoms or not
receiving the suggestions. And we try to see if we can
provide an alert to these individuals and invite them to do an
early testing.
We figured out a lot
by running this. Some of the results are negative,
meaning it's extremely difficult to talk and
provide this information to participant and force them to do
any action.
Everybody's really interested, is engaged, continue to wear the device,
but making them doing an action in this context, at least, turned out
to be really complicated then. We figured out that even the time in which you
provide the information may matter a lot,
the context, and so we need to keep all of that into
consideration. So this is about infectious
diseases, and I hope this can help really in
the detection of many other disease in the same
context.
Then I want to switch into precision
nutrition. This was a trial
that we finished really last year.
And
here we have-- Well, first of all, the
focus here, at least for us, was on the
early prediction of who will develop type 2
diabetes,
especially for individuals who are pre-diabetic.
Type 2 diabetes is extremely common in the US.
About 50% of the adult population has some sort of
metabolic disease and
a full knowledge of what is happening may help these people
by being more active,
eat more healthy, and control their weight, if they
know a little bit better what is happening.
And
we set up a study with
1,000 individuals.
Some of them are normoglycemic, so healthy, some are pre-diabetic,
some already have type 2 diabetes.
And we collected
really a multi-model
amount of data. So for each of them, we provided a
sensor to monitor continuously sleep, heart, and
activityWe provided them with continuous glucose
monitoring to check their glucose for about 10 days.
We collected food intake and different surveys.
We connected with their electronic health records.
And again, this was
quite impressive. We are
recruiting individuals all around the United States and
fully remotely, and we have their consent, and then we collect
their EHR data without them needing to do any active
actions beyond the consent itself.
And then
finally, we were also testing how we can collect
blood, saliva, and stool samples, again, fully
remotely without them visiting a clinic.
We just send them the kit with the right explanation of what
they need to do. We collected these three samples, and we got information
on their value of the HbA1c from the blood, basically where they are in
their type 2 diabetes
journey, their genetic data from saliva, and their information
about their gut microbiome from the stool sample.
With all this data,
this multimodal data,
we studied their
glucose spikes and how they change over time, and this
result was published last summer.
And
I can give you a couple of
points that were quite interesting.
First, we look at the general statistics, and we look at
how
the mean glucose level is the simplest one that you
see in the top left. It's quite different between
normoglycemic, pre-diabetic, and type 2 diabetics.
And we saw the most interesting probably is the bottom
left one, which is the spike resolution.
So we studied also on average, how long does it take from a
spike to go back to normal? And we show
that there are significant differences between these three groups,
even if
there are some overlaps. So it's not enough really to distinguish
between them. But the most interesting was we tried to
put all this data together. We studied the different
correlations between all this data, and then we design a
classifier.
This was for a very simple task, distinguishing between
normoglycemic and type 2 diabetics.
This classifier works very well,
got an AUC of 0.96, 97.
The point is, how do we use it?
Well, this was designed not really to do this
task, but to obtain a number, which is zero
for fully normoglycemic or one for individual who
are type 2 diabetics. And then using this number
to design a sort of a risk score for individuals who are pre-diabetic.
And this was really interesting and as you see here, this
is data for pre-diabetic individuals,
and usually they are classified based on their one value of
HbA1c.
And what we've seen here is
for the same value-- Well, higher HbA1c
means higher risk profile on average.
But on an individual level, there are individuals with the same value of the
HbA1c who have actually a really different
risk profile, meaning they really behave
like type 2 diabetics, or they really behave like
an individual who is normoglycemic
in terms of their physiological data.
And so we're basically defining a risk score that can go
beyond the HbA1c and
potentially alert certain individuals that things are going
good or bad
based on
all this collected data.
And
we validated this through an independent external data set.
So the idea here is now we can collect a lot of
data. We have the tools to put together all this data.
And I want to explore now also yet another dimension.
The really interesting thing here is
what if we can collect this data not for
months or for a specific study, but potentially for very long?
What if we can follow participants for years?
What information do we get, and what information can we return to participants?
And you can think about
many different cases in which it's important to see when things are
changing for a participant.
We focus here on one specific example in maternal health,
and
this was
quite
interesting. We're following these
women. These are about 100 women, and now we extended the
study to more than 2,000 women
from pre-pregnancy, during the pregnancy,
and also postpartum.
As you can see there beside the normal
fluctuation in the menstrual cycle for the resting heart rate
during the pre-pregnancy, we have an increase in the resting
heart rate at the beginning of the pregnancy, which is a
maximum, then modulated by hormones, hCG in
particular. It goes down and
reaches a minimum around week nine or 10. These are averages over all these women.
And then goes up until about eight to nine weeks before
deliveryAnd then starts to go down.
This is all
modulated by the different hormones that plays a role
there. And it's quite interesting as we're trying to
do with a larger data set now, trying to do a prediction,
especially of preterm birth. Try to figure out which women is
at higher risk for preterm birth and also other
complications, and how we can
basically try to intervene earlier.
So
I think this is a good example of how we
can follow participant for years.
And again, in a fully passive way. We're
working with Fitbit devices, but also Oura, but also
Apple Watch, whatever device they may have,
we can integrate it in our platform and follow them for
several years.
Let me go quickly into two more topics.
One is on the cardiovascular care
and in particular, cardiac monitoring,
which I understand is also very important for
oncologist patient.
We see here an example of
what we can do. Here we are monitoring individuals for about two
weeks with a patch, and we're trying to solve a
quite interesting problem.
The point with atrial fibrillation or these rhythm
abnormalities is that they can happen
at some days, and they can disappear for several weeks and
then happen again.
So even a long monitoring period of about two weeks may not be
sufficient to detect who has these rhythm
abnormalities and potentially treat them.
We are instructing here a deep learning algorithm to
look at the patients in normal sinus rhythm
and trying to predict if they have,
before or after, if they have any rhythm abnormality.
And this is
our prediction algorithm. We get quite good
performance also here about more than
0.8 in AUC.
And
this is done with a data set of about 400,000
individuals worth of data.
I want to move to the very last point. I have two minutes.
So
this is where I think things are going in this
monitoring with wearable devices.
So one important future direction is the
one of agentic AI.
The idea here is that we can now
automatically talk with participant and this is
a work from people from Google.
It's a white paper in which they showed how they envision
this agentic AI working with real individuals.
They envision, in particular, three agents.
A data science agent who is able to process and
analyze the data, a domain expert who is able to
interpret this data and understand what's happening,
eventually calling a human expert
if it's the case. And a health coach agent, which is
equally important, is an agent that can talk,
that can understand the patient, can understand the request from the
patient, and return potentially only the information that the patient really
want.
And my very last slide here.
So this is a very recent paper, came out
a couple of weeks ago,
again from Fitbit. And I think this is really
revealing one important aspect. So we're talking about these
Fitbit devices, and you have seen how in many of our studies we need
a very large number of individuals.
What they have shown here, beside the particular
topic, which is prediction of insulin resistance, but they have shown how
they can observe very
large unlabeled data sets. So
people just using the device,
and they can learn a foundation model.
This is a model that can basically
understand this data, translate the data into a much
more compact format, and enable then the use
of any prediction algorithms learned from
not maybe 10,000 individuals, but maybe by
10 or 20 individuals. So a very small
number of positive cases. I think this is super powerful
and
it's a great work published in "Nature" that just show
how this is possible and how they made it possible through
this foundation model.
And yeah, I think this general physiological
representation may also turn out to be super
important if we fine-tune it for specific oncologies tasks.
This concludes my talk and yeah, I'm
ready for any questions. Thank you so much.
As a recovering Scripps research faculty member, of course, I have to apologize
that I said UCSD.
But
so again, open for questions, please use the microphone
as said before. Giorgio, so
maybe somewhat similar question
for Carissa as well, right, is
how early-- What is that time? And again, we struggled with
this as well. I don't think there's a clean answer, right?
But at some point, we have to say, "Okay, what's that time window of observation
when I actually say
I need-- there's an intervention that needs to be triggered.
How do you even start thinking about this? In any one of those, right?
Yeah.
The preterm birth is probably the most important one
there,
because it's not about just...
Yeah, it's about how early can you raise that flag.
I think this is really the main dependent.
The idea in all this works is really to study the
individual, as I mentioned from the beginning, understand
what is the normal, let's say, for the individual, and
really trigger changes with respect to this normal.
And now, how early can you do a prediction?
It really depends on what is this. Infectious
diseases or preterm birth are very different, of course.
But the idea is really to see differences and try to
interpret these differences, see how consistent the differences are,
and then do an intervention. For infectious diseases, for example,
we did not trigger any alarm if a change was lasting only one day,
because it can be really anything.
The alarm, since it has a cost also for the participant, we try to
trigger it only if we are pretty sure that there is something consistent happening.
And so we usually waited at least a couple of days, and we look at changes in
resting heart rate and in at least one between sleep and
physical activity
before triggering an alarm. So, it pretty much depends
and...
In the back.
So if you're enrolling people from all over the United States and you're giving
them results, how are you dealing with scope of practice and medical
licensure?
It really depends on what the study is about.
So I think for certain studies that we have done,
this was not a problem. The main issue
there was to have the consent, of
course, for any data that we were collecting from any patient.
We were not providing any medical advice to these
patients. We are always providing suggestions, even in the case
in which we return the result for infectious diseases.
We're not telling them, "You have a disease," or something.
We are telling them, "Something is changing with your physiological
data. We
suggest you to do a test and verify if you really have a
problem or not." So it's a really big problem what you're
raising, and something we need to deal with.
Yeah. So social media can't tell you that you're too fat anymore,
and it's their fault if you feel too fat and you're a teenager.
So I worry that if we use a chatbot-type
AI, I call it a chatbot, an AI device to tell people
information about their health, and there's no licensed
provider involved, that we'll be in big trouble.
This is absolutely true, and we do not want, again, to return
medical
answers to these people. We want to
invite them to a study. We want to explain maybe what the
data is, but then always suggest for anything more
serious to go to a real doctor. I absolutely agree,
this is a huge problem.
Hi there. It's Chuchan Hong, Russell Park.
It's so great that you could do all these national studies.
I'm just wondering, in these studies, are you able to reach
underserved minority populations and how you actually do that
recruitment?
It's a great question and a great goal on our side
also.
So we are always trying to target
diverse population there,
and in progress, in particular, the one with a thousand in
the
focusing on type 2 diabetes. We did a big effort there.
There are two aspects here. One, that on our advantage is that
we can really reach anybody, so they don't need to be a
patient at any big hospital.
They just need to have an internet connection and
see some of our advertisement through different means.
On the opposite side, at least for some of the studies, we recruit individuals who
have a wearable device. That, of course, is biasing towards
a certain population.
So it pretty much depends. I think in this digital
way,
by providing the devices, in this case, we have an
opportunity to really diversify the population in a way that we cannot do it with
more standard, let's say, clinical trials.
Okay, thank you.
Hi, thank you. Thank you very much.
I have a quick question, maybe more methodological.
How do you deal with telling if the device is really working?
If
say you're looking at the data and you find that someone's sleeping two hours a
night, do you know that's a problem or that person to be aware of?
Or is the device just not working? How do you filter out
those-
It's a great point
... potential situations?
In some extent, it's also connected to the previous question, meaning if it is
a problem, we cannot really tell the participant, "This is a problem.
You should sleep more. You should sleep less."
We can eventually highlight to them that we see that they are
sleeping two hours.
It's very complicated. Usually, we trust
the devices and what they can-- For the simple type of
data that they can,
like resting heart rate, amount of sleep, or
activityThey are usually quite accurate.
The main issues in the data comes from misuse of the
device, potentially not wearing the device for long periods of time and
so on. We have a way now to track that, and so we
are also keeping that in mind in our analysis.
So we know when an individual is wearing the device or not
wearing the device. And of course, if individual is not wearing it for, let's say,
10 hours a day,
we don't have an accurate measure, for example, of sleep, and even activity
may be affected. So we keep that in mind into
our analysis.
We cannot force the individual. Of course, we can encourage them to wear it as much
as they can, but then it's their own choice what they want to do.
Hi, thank you. That was actually kind of a good segue into my question about
longitudinal monitoring. So when it comes to the actual data
and dropouts, say, the patient takes off their wearable device for a
certain amount of time,
and in terms of the way the model is constructed, how do you deal
with both those missing values, and how does the
model deal with the time factor of
weighing, say, nearer measurements more heavily on the
outcome for, say, a risk factor profile than
measurements from a year ago?
So,
two excellent questions. How do we deal with missing data?
There is not much, really. We can try to interpolate it.
We usually try to avoid that because
we're basically guessing that everything remains the same, while it may
not.
And we're potentially being convinced
of certain things that are not really true.
So usually we deal it like proper missing data,
and we just say, "Well, we cannot really get to any conclusion
for this amount of days in which the individual is not wearing it properly."
As part of some of this study, we also think about incentives
to help the individual potentially wear the device more and
eventually remind the individuals to wear the device.
They may work or may not work depending really on case by case.
So that's quite complicated.
Regarding the second question, can you repeat it again?
Oh, sure. So I was wondering if your model incorporated
the time decay factor, essentially.
Sure.
So, yeah.
That is true in any of the
studies that we have done. For infectious diseases, for example,
first of all, we consider changes with respect to the recent
past. So we take a window of approximately two months
before
the eventual event, in this case, an infectious disease,
and see if in the last couple of days, there is a significant difference with
respect to the previous two months.
We try to forget data that is too far in the past.
Again, this was for that specific
analysis. For any
single cases, any context, we have slightly different choices.
But this is a really important point.
We don't consider all the data the same.
We consider the time, and we try to
decide what
technique to use based on the specific context.
Thank you.
Thank you, Giorgio.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
And now to our final speaker, George Niava from USC, who's going to bring it back
to oncologic practice and how wearable sensors and sensor data in
general together with algorithms might actually influence clinical practice,
including what barriers are ahead of us to overcome. George, all yours.
Thank you, Peter. So the fundamental thing that you
get from sensor data is you're getting data from patients.
And so I'm going to talk to you about the limitations of that
data that comes from patients, trying to understand where AI
integration should be done. We'll give you some examples, and
then we'll suggest what's going to happen in the future.
So the first thing is that AI is very good at time
series data, and I think you've seen some very nice examples of time series data
from Giorgio and Christina.
Glucose monitoring, ambulatory blood pressure monitoring, cardiac rhythm
monitoring,
and vital sign monitoring of hospitalized patients are all
areas where it's been clinically shown that having time
series data is superior to episodic data.
It leads to early detection of decompensation, better care,
personalized care. And so the question really that we're
asking when we're looking at wearables is, are these tools
which have been very nicely applied in very specific situations,
should they be applied more broadly to fitness and
activity?
And I think everybody got really excited about
continuous patient-reported data
after this 2016 presentation, which was a plenary at the
ASCO meeting from Ethan Basch, which showed that if
patients simply told a computer
how they were feeling and what was going on with their life,
they actually had better survival than if they were monitored by routine
CT scanning.
And this was for lung cancer patients.
So this was very exciting. It showed that they had improvement along
all series of
metrics. And you would've thought after this presentation was
made that we would be doing remote patient
monitoring for everybody with lung cancer, or maybe all cancers,
because it improved survival.
But it didn't happen. And it didn't happen
becauseA lot of patients aren't health literate,
can't really do digital health things.
A lot of patients don't want to do weekly check-ins.
Clinicians get alert fatigue and really oftentimes don't want to
hear what's
happening to every one of their patients.
Here are places where AI can really be
a solution. A lot of physicians, I'm not going to say older
physicians, but there's a lot of skepticism in some demographics.
And then the question of staffing, who's really watching all of this, and who's
paying for it? The health systems are really interested
in revenue. They're really not that interested in increasing
expenses.
The IT departments at hospitals are incredibly backed up,
they're expensive to work with, and they don't like to do pilot
projects that aren't directly linked to revenue.
And
so when you look at the six and a half million cancer
patients
that were looked at in the Medicare database, and you ask them, how often was the
remote patient monitoring code billed for one of those patients,
it was less than 1% of the time.
And then the big downer was that when
the BOCH study was repeated in the PROTECT trial, the
survival benefit wasn't seen in follow-up in 2025,
although it was able to detect fewer emergency room
visits and better preservation of physical functioning for those
patients who were put on remote patient
monitoring.
Now, it's not to say that health systems are totally against remote patient
monitoring and patient-generated health data.
There's a bunch of patient-generated health data that they really, really
like.
They like psychosocial distress monitoring.
They love patients entering their own history into history forms.
They like to get information about quality of life.
They like patient-reported outcome metrics.
These things are relatively easy to collect.
These are things that are all linked to some metric of quality care that's been
imposed on the hospital system by
one of the various regulators that they deal with.
And remote patient monitoring, though, does work.
This is an example of some obesity trials where they showed that if the
patients are entered into a remote patient monitoring program, they
lose more weight than if they get routine care just in the office.
Now, I'll have you pay attention to the degree of benefit here.
You see that it's a couple of pounds.
And this is what AI can do.
This is data from the Noom app,
for those who've used Noom.
And this is in breast cancer patients showing just
how much difference there is in weight loss, looking
here at differences of 5% of body weight,
which can be achieved if you tailor a customized
artificial intelligence to coach people on weight loss.
But any time you think about putting people into some kind of
application,
not everybody's as good as Dr. Lo is at getting
long-term adherence.
And you'll see that for many studies,
the step count goes down and the
compliance goes down with time of enrollment.
And this is even true with wearables,
which you'd think would be relatively easy.
We do see a lot better adherence early on in the study.
We generally see less adherence later.
And this is some data from our group,
where we took some patients who had lung cancer,
who we decided we're going to treat them with a PD-1
checkpoint inhibitor at home
with subcutaneous administration, and we're going to have all the visits be by
telemedicine. We're not going to make them come into the office.
We're going to give them their drug at home, and we're going to see
them just by telemedicine and monitor them with wearables.
And we ask them to upload their vital signs just before their doctor's visits.
And what you can see is that compliance is very different
depending on which specific task you're asking them to do.
Vital sign compliance was really good because they knew they were about to see me,
and they'd get yelled at if they didn't upload their vital signs, right?
But wearing the Fitbit was not as good for a lot of people.
Some people had trouble
remembering to charge the device. We didn't have the one-week charging.
We were more on the three-day charging plan.
And
then completing surveys, quality of life surveys.
People just sometimes just don't get around to it.
When you think about cancer patients and activity,
I think Georgia did a very nice job of talking about how variable it is
among different patient populations.
And this is a nice meta-analysis done by Gillian Gresham,
show that cancer patients are not super active in
general.
Some of these people are walking 3,000, 4,000 steps a day.
Some studies have higher numbers.
But the important thing to keep in mind is that it's not
patients getting to the point where they're not running marathons and they're not
going out jogging. The real question for many of these cancer patients is,
did they vacuum their carpet or not?
And physical functioning is one place that is
ripe for AI tools to help us solve the
problem.
This is an old study done out of the Mayo Clinic
Consortium,
which looked at measurement of performance status.
Now, for those of you who measure performance status using the ECOG
scale, you know there's only five choices.The
patients are up and active,
they can be bedridden, and then they can have various degrees of bedridden in
between. So if you were to ask
a roll of the dice how often you would be accurate to hit
the same
performance status measurement,
with the physician being asked what the performance status is and the patient being
asked what they think their performance status is.
If it was random, you'd be right 20% of the time.
If you're a physician, you're only right 40% of the time.
And this is something where you'd think it'd be
relatively simple, and it's not.
And the problem is that when there's disagreement between the patient
and the physician in terms of what the patient's performance status
is,
there is an increased risk of death for the patient.
It leads to over-treatment, and it leads to under-treatment.
Most of the time, the physicians are overestimating performance
status.
And to give you a sense of how much of a difference it is, it's about a
16% difference in survival, which is approximately the
same benefit that you get from giving cisplatin chemotherapy
in the adjuvant setting to a lung cancer patient.
So we asked
an AI tool,
Xbox Kinect,
to look at people as they move
from the chair in the examination room,
getting onto the table in the examination room.
And we measured velocity,
acceleration of that movement, and we were able to
calculate a performance status score from that camera
of how the patient is doing.
Now, to give you a sense of
how nice that is,
the heat map that you see on the left is
how 35 different patients
were scored looking at the video of the
same movement, and what performance status score the patient was given on the
Karnofsky Scale.
And you can see here, physician number three is extremely pessimistic.
Physician number one and four are much more optimistic.
Physician number two is in the middle.
But what you can see here is that there's a tremendous amount of variability in how
the human eye scores activity.
And here's a place where AI can help, and this is work done by
Chris Wang in our group.
And we know that,
as Dr. Lo showed, having
low levels of activity for a cancer patient leads to
more problems, and this is some data looking at
patients with a variety of different cancers.
They were all receiving highly immunogenic chemotherapy
and they
were asked to wear a Fitbit. Or in this case, it wasn't a Fitbit, it was a
Microsoft Band at the time.
And what you can see is that the patients weren't
very active. The patients on the left
had fewer than
five hours of non-sedentary activity over a
60-day period. The patients on the far right had more than 40 hours
of non-sedentary activity over a 60-day period.
And when you look at the amalgamation of all the different problems that these
people can have, from emergency room visits to urgent office
visits to hospitalizations to having to go into the day hospital
for infusions and other supportive activities, the active
patients do much better.
Now whether or not you can change people's activity to
get them to be more fit, that's something
where here again, AI does a better job than
either being given exercise logs to
keep or being asked
just how you're doing with routine care.
If you provide somebody with an accelerometer and you provide
them with that type of direct feedback,
you can get patients to achieve their level of recommended
exercise, and this is from a study in people with pancreatic
cancer.
But we don't want to limit the patient-generated health data to
just wearables. Ideally, we want to integrate
across various domains to get the most information we can
from smartphone surveys,
patient-reported outcomes, information from their electronic medical
record, laboratory data, imaging data.
Trying to process that all together and then
give a model information that goes to the
clinician or goes to the patient.
But it's not always that easy. This is a
group out of Denmark that tried to incorporate this
type of data framework
in patients with cancer.
And they initially enrolled everyone and found
that about a third of them, the physicians thought they couldn't even
comply.
And this happens more often than you think.
If someone doesn't own a smartphone,
I can just about assure you they're not going to be able to
handle a study that involves a smartphone and a wearable.
And there are still many people who choose not to own these devices.
Ultimately, they enrolled 10 patients and weren't able to get very
good compliance.And this is an
example that I like to show because this is the type of
integration that we want to be able to do.
This is the likelihood that someone has a lesion on CT
scan and the likelihood that that lesion is cancer.
And here we integrated data from the PET
scan and the SUV value of the lesion, and we also integrated
data from a measurement of circulating tumor cells in peripheral
blood and circulating tumor cell clusters and found that
whenever you combine data, you
achieve much better ability to
predict any particular clinical outcome.
But the secret here is that you have to do it across domains, and you have to do it
across domains that normally don't talk to one another.
Usually, the clinical laboratory does not talk to the radiologist.
And so these types of multi-modality
models, this is a study that was just published last year,
where they looked at laboratory values, including albumin measurements,
resting heart rate, age of the patient, results of
patient-reported outcome studies to try to predict the likelihood that the
patient would end up in the urgent care center.
And found that you can get the AUC all the way up to
86%
if you also incorporate smartphone data on heart rate
and sleep efficiency into the model.
You do a better job than if you just build the model on things that might
be present in the electronic medical record.
And you can do the same thing with predicting death.
This is something that's important for deciding when patients need to
enroll in hospice care. If you combine
things like heart rate, steps, appetite, how they're
urinating, where the patient is in their disease
trajectory, and include a little bit of data from the electronic medical
record, you can develop fairly good predictive
models
in terms of the probability that the patient
is not going to survive the next seven days.
And that's something that's obviously valuable to the patients and
family for future planning and also important for deciding
about healthcare utilization in that time period.
You can also build models to predict very specific clinical
encounter information. So this is
a number of different features,
including things like diarrhea, joint pain,
fatigue, rash, visual disturbances.
Many different domains are on here, and this is the probability of the
patients having an immune reaction to their
checkpoint inhibitor.
So this is something we always worry about, particularly
when we're doing clinical trials where the patients are being treated with
checkpoint inhibitors as an outpatient, or when you think about the
interval now on dosing immune checkpoint
inhibitors is now every six weeks for
pembrolizumab. You wonder if you send somebody out for six weeks at a
time, you want to be able to have some kind of predictor
that they're not having an event that needs an
intervention if you're going to have a long time between office visits.
And more of these sorts of models are being tested.
This is being done now in Europe. It's a large
multinational effort across
four European hospitals in three different countries,
looking at breast and prostate cancer patients who are being treated with curative
intent therapy to try to correlate different
metrics that can be measured
from patient-reported outcome data and other
clinical outcomes.
Unfortunately, so far, the only thing that's been published is a link between
sleep and urinary symptoms, but this is something that is
continuously being refined and worked on to try to get
to a more
important metrics.
So to summarize, I'm very excited about wearables and
patient-generated health data.
But I really do think that it needs a layer of
artificial intelligence in order to make these continuous results
interpretable, in order to get them to be adopted, and in order to get that
adoption to be acceptable to the health system.
And we still have a ways to go to fix the patient adherence problem.
Thank you.
Thank you, Horry.
Let's open this for questions and maybe actually keep it broad.
If you have questions to individual speakers, please say so.
And again, let's use the microphone, please.
It's interesting what came through with each one of you, but maybe
Horry can talk to this first.
Because you're not arguing that AI is the great
solution for everything, but for this
particular instance, actually,
the
simple single parameter threshold approach
is just not working.
Mm-hmm.
And what we're now seeing seems to be an actual sort of
direction, a set of solutions that can actually push
us over the finish line, if we argue finish line is
really clinical practice.
Yeah, no, I think Giorgio did a very nice job of showing
that getting an infection is a lot like going to Europe.
And so we're not going to be able to be setting things
along
by single parameters. We're going to have to know what the heart
rate is doingWhere the patient is geographically, what
clinical stage
the person is in their course of disease, whether or not they've got circulating
tumor cells. The problem is that we currently have
all these bits of information, and they're all siloed separately.
And the place where AI's really going to be successful
is where that siloed information can cross-talk with one another,
and then we can really start to build some useful predictive models.
I think there's been some early work suggesting that it's
doable,
but there's a number of silo breaking that needs to happen to
make it really effective.
So maybe a quick response from each one of the three of you.
We'll start with Georgia this time around, and that is, again, this is an
educational session.
So it's really about, hey, where are we at next year?
What are we going to present next year and maybe the year after?
So pick either 12 months or 24 months,
and what is it that we, as a field...
You can use yourself, your own laboratory, whichever way around, but what is it
that's going to be different
in either 12 or 24 months from now?
So I guess what I am really excited about is
what I presented at the very end. Now, these capabilities
of these new models, and so really not only the data
collection, but the analysis of this type of data.
I mentioned foundation models, and I mentioned agentic AI.
And
I would say the horizon is really in 12 months,
because the field is changing so rapidly, actually.
Just a couple of years ago, foundation models were not a thing, and we were
not even thinking about the possibility of this unsupervised learning from
data that has nothing to do with our studies, and then reusing it in the
studies. Agentic AI is even more recent.
There are a lot of problems, as we highlighted those in the discussion,
but immense potential, if done properly.
And so what we will be able to demonstrate in 12 months, I think,
will be very interesting in that area.
Carissa.
These timescales are tough. For 24 months, what I think we really need here
is larger data sets, as we talked about a little bit beforehand.
I think having the siloed data that Georgia's referring to does make it hard to
draw generalizable conclusions that apply across different
settings and disease groups and devices.
And so,
maybe it would be possible for us to put our heads together or
use some of the methods, the decentralized digital trial methods that
Georgia's group use, or that Giorgio's group uses,
to generate that. I think in the short term, what our group is doing is really
focusing on how can we help patients and clinicians work with the data
directly. So I think there's too much danger in prediction with the small data
sets that we have of being wrong. So the lower
risk approach that we've been taking is, how can we make the
data
easy to interpret, easy to view, and let people draw their own conclusions?
Yeah, we had a question earlier in the talk where people
highlighted the regulatory problems here.
And so
I think the solution to our regulatory
problem is already there. It just
needs to be implemented. We can all already access our own health records.
And we can all access our own wearable data, and we can all access our own
patient-generated symptom scores.
But what we can't do is take that as a patient
and convert that health data, which is HIPAA protected and firewall protected
and has all sorts of regulatory issues around it, and convert it into
just data,
which can now be shared and used and
models can be built on. So I think the
solution
is to overcome this regulatory hurdle on the health
data side, because I think all the other aspects
are already cleared.
Okay. 12 months or 24 months?
Which administration is...
Let's go with 24 for now.
Okay.
Cool. Go ahead.
Thank you very much. Great talks.
I'm Suzette Delage from France. My question is, you mentioned
adoption that has been so poor for certain
past devices and past solutions, and
I'm wondering whether the metrics that are used are
not only based on the physician's use and not on the
patient's viewed impact. And,
well, patient's adoption to me, for instance, are much
higher in
diabetes, for instance, where they see
very easily what is the impact for them.
Whereas for cancer patients, and we have, well, many patients
in different programs of wearable devices and remote
follow-up, et cetera.
And indeed, they do not clearly see what is the impact for themselves.
And I think having participative
research and something that would be
more patient impact driven could drive the patients
to help us convince the authorities and increase
adoption to me. Well, I think the field
has been a bit too much driven by physicians,
at least in my view.
I couldn't agree more with you that the issue is that
the diabetic patients have a very concrete
understanding-
Of course
... of what their blood sugar is, what it needs to be, and they have something they
can do.... to impact it. And I think
for cancer patients, it's all very much more ethereal.
Yeah, I should exercise more. I should eat a little bit better.
It's almost like many of our tools
are more about helping the health system.
So we had all these questions about, "Well, just how much lead time can I tell
before my patient's going to get sick
so that we can maybe put them on some monitoring?"
But I think you're right. This the-
We need biomarkers or at least metrics that would speak to them,
telling-
Mm-hmm
... well, even the heart pace, even, well, things that they
would think meaningful and would make them changed our
behavior also.
Yeah.
Every once in a while, you'll get the occasional patient who's hugely engaged.
We had one patient-
Of course
... that we put on a Fitbit study who
proceeded to take 35,000 steps a day- ...
because he knew that his physician was now watching.
That's too much.
Thank you very much.
Okay, last question.
This is kind of a general question for the whole panel.
I feel like what follows sometimes when people talk about
multimodal data is the question about if
anything is going to get integrated into digital twins.
That's for everybody, yeah.
I think that's a methodology, which is definitely
possible.
It pretty much depends on the context.
So sure, we can build this system
that somehow mimics a patient
and can predict what the patient goes.
I don't have a lot of experience in how
effective they are, really, in this prediction and so on, so I can't
speak much on that. But, it pretty much depends on the context, yeah.
So there's a couple of groups building digital twins, molecular twins, however you
want to
think about this. It's an interesting question you're raising, and that is
because there's models being built over there on the digital twin side, right?
Is now
building models over here on the wearable side, and et
cetera, right? So,
I think that would be fun, because I don't know how, fun
to explore how these models would actually then interact.
And because, again, Georgia, throughout the agentic AI world, right?
So I mean, that should really then be the ability, right,
to have those two actually interacting with each other as opposed
to the attempt of trying to build a mega model.
Interesting construct.
I fully agree. At the very end, it depends what the goal is.
And so, the studies that I presented, for example, the goal
was clear in the specific context, was prediction of
infections,
in the maternal health is prediction of
preterm birth now and some other complications that we're studying
or prediction of type 2 diabetes. It really much depends, and then
depending on what you have, it may make sense to use digital twins, and so
building a model around the patients or do other type
of modeling. So, it's hard to say.
The multimodal aspect is just enriching the
space immensely because now you put together
from electronic health records, and so all their past medical
records to the continuous wearable signals, to
any type of
measurements that maybe
once.
It may drive to a digital twin or may drive to another model that is
equally
maybe focused on the specific case and yeah.
But it's a fantastic educational tool for the
patient, right? If you can say, like, "Okay, here's your digital
twins, and this is what happened when we did therapy X.
This is what happened when we did therapy Y.
This is what happened when you exercised and ate right.
This is what happened when you
decided to enroll in a particular clinical trial,
and these was the probabilistic outcomes for all of that."
I think that it's great for patients particularly that
are very literate in statistics and
probabilities. I think it's much more problematic for the ones that
aren't literate in statistics and probabilities.
Yeah, I think a lot of the time that stuff gets communicated to the clinician
before the patient, just so there's kind of like a filtering-
Mm-hmm
... information instead of having someone grapple with their own-
... statistics in four-choice scenarios.
Yeah.
Yeah, that assumes, though, that the physicians all understand probability and
statistics. But leaving that aside for the moment-
... just because that seems a good way to
close the session. Again, thank you very much to the audience.
Again, thank you for the patients and advocates who were here with us today.
And of course, a huge thank you to the speakers. Much appreciated. Thank you.